in the last couple of days there's been
quite a large discussion about some
breakdown the Large Hadron Collider this
is the huge physics experiment in Geneva
and there has been a substantial loss of
helium nobody's not quite sure how much
into the experiment now you could ask
why does anybody doing experiments into
the big bang need helium and the answer
is that the apparatus is like a huge
circle and it has charged particles
protons going round and round and so
these particles have to bend round the
corner and to make it Bend they need
very powerful magnets and the helium
comes in for making the magnets really
powerful and the way you make a magnet
some of you've may have done this before
is you take a piece of wire and you wind
it round into a coil like this around my
finger and if you want to make it really
powerful you do make a huge number of
turns of the kuo going round and round
and so the strength of the magnetic
field depends on the number of coils and
and the current going through the wire
and the bigger the current the more
turns the bigger the magnetic field but
of course as you make the wire longer
and longer to get more more turns when
you put a current through it it starts
heating up just like any sort of
electric heater and if you get it too
big the current will just melt the whole
magnet so if you want a really powerful
magnet then what you do is you have to
make it out of a material which has no
electrical resistance so however much
current you put through within reason it
will not heat up at all because the wire
has no resistance and to do this you
need to take a material so called
superconductor which you cool to very
low temperature and then suddenly it
loses all its electrical resistance
and liquid helium is the best coolant
for doing this because it can cool
materials down to its boiling point of 4
degrees Kelvin or if you pump on it with
a vacuum pump rather like taking your
tea to boil it at the top of a mountain
that boiling point gives even lower just
below 2 degrees absolute that's minus
271 degrees centigrade and then you can
get really powerful magnets and whatever
has gone wrong in the LHC is involved in
the magnets suddenly boiling off a large
amount of helium so the reason why
helium has such a low boiling point is
because in a liquid the molecules or in
the case of helium there's only one atom
in the molecule in a liquid have a
positive interaction they interact they
attract each other which makes it form a
liquid rather than the gas and the
stronger the interaction between the
molecules the higher the boiling point
water has strong interaction between the
molecules so it boils at 100 degrees
centigrade mercury has an even stronger
interaction so it boils at a higher
temperature and helium has a combination
of being a very light atom and having a
very weak interaction and it is the
combination of very light atom and very
weak interaction that gives this low
boiling point
yeah ready yeah very satisfying reaction